autant interview gaz moutarde gainsbarre
superstar est superbe our way si
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
désormais you are under arrest faudra
pas dire que tu dormais pour moi c'est
galbert peuvent également écouter
sérieux at il dit quoi est encore sur
des dvd va pas tu te regarde dans la
glace
je m'habille et voiliers en été nous ça
peut être un parti o'neill jeudi à ubu
s'échangent les squales c'est ce que
certains je changerais rien changé que
manquait il en est du genre
rechargeable hui coup et il ya des
petits quand été convenu
tu voulais ressembler à quoi je connais
une phase de picabia qui est moi
monsieur je me déguise en homme pour
n'être rien tb06 sur insidieuse à
strasbourg dans les parent qui t'ai vu
mourir comme jeune dix mois ci et des
cuirs s'était pas de l'intrépidité c'est
du courage parce que l'instabilité c'est
le sait et on change la question
le courage c'est de vaincre ses peurs
où elle est mon petit gars ce voyage
bourg tu penses que tu vas mourir quand
quelques revues pour bientôt un support
de mathématiques
quand je vais crever
sur un coup j'espère c'est que
s'envoyant en l'air
bellemare
mais sans doute plus en envoyant ce
qu'il faut class classe classe et tu te
souviens 47 48 et jours que des pc chez
delhi avec le sel ont tapissé d'astral
j'avais les clés il était que la caisse
voilà je crois c'est pour ça j'ai tout
est noir j'aime pas
que c'était mon marché il avait des
chiens
[ __ ] aurait dit
par lesquels jouent à 10 h salle
le haut du rhin fait et j'ai trahi les
fissures à l'italien carré de trois
mètres sur trois que je vais il m est
par terre il y avait des micros des
picasso les délits
sa maman de soufre et de et du super
duke et pourquoi tu as brûlé tête ou à
l'âge de 30 ans des croûtes
il peut brûler il ya eu le couteau à
deux peintres but puis je change de
temps à passer du d'expressionnisme
dadaïsme surréalisme cubisme
après siège puisse pas d'échangé entre
norme des cinq ans au sérieux maintenant
être piégé en 1959 déclaré 30 ans
je chante pour pouvoir un jour reprendre
la peinture expliqué sur tille
battant sa part si j'ai encore tué
j'arrête de boire d'attendre je prends
le bas j'ai encore une écrite et
visuelle une phrase de la croix c'est
très cruel mais qui est superbe
ils ceux ci un peintre doit savoir
attraper au vol un ouvrier tombant d'un
échafaudage dans le temps qu'ils ont
mais tu attends plus dur
entre guînes vu un gainsbourg et
gainsbarre
j'aurais préféré gourou le peintre de
larmes
je suis bien q quel menu sur les clients
quand t'es pas content in the bear il ya
un musée
les machines bien l'encadrer aussi les
boues tableau j'ai tiré ces pièces sont
tués est-ce qu'il est de rejoindre
toulon en fut rien jour tu crois pas
qu'ils souhaitent un pour toi de
rejoindre un beau en abyssinie un
extrait pas
oh
ouais pour moi c'est devant avec picabéa
parce que je suis qui a pas lu
jésus-christ rastaquouère et vous il ya
beaucoup puisqu'il a tiré quelques
exemplaires on est servi par les cons
d'ailleurs trouvé le premier était un
conte 15 bars et je t'emmerde
evgeny sokolov tu passes un bouquin ou
que gallimard est publié parce que cette
aide soit 1 mais oui messieurs entre eux
entre de [ __ ] par ordre alphabétique
entre surprend très jeune et gide à faux
le veut en faire je n'ai
rien jour tu as dit
je ne peux te réponds pas trop con
l'homme a créé les dieux n'inverse reste
à prouver
toujours été un pays non je crois que je
viens
politis mme à dire je vais toujours les
duos coûts n'ont plus rien de peur et
les acquis qui le pra nous met dans
mauvaises nouvelles des étoiles
j'ai dit dieu que c'est tout simple
jésus était de race sémite
elle a dit je suis fils de dieu est
rentré
1942 tuant vous français savoir que j'ai
une étoile de shérif je n'en veux pas à
la wehrmacht plutôt d'epo mais qu'il
faisait l'occupation j'en veux aux
miliciens au fond les prescriptions pas
forme coup c'est vrai que parler hier
pendant une perquisition de cacher
quelques kilomètres dans l'adoption de
la carte d'état-major dixit
puis j'ai eu des soucis de ré et ça
c'est un des plus importants coucou
il pose une colle et comme type lokon
qui mènera sûrement l'envié levée qui a
coulé le titanic iceberg en core un juif